actually say they say 40 men report to
not be having but what they don't report
is they're not not having sex because of
women it's because they don't feel
confident in themselves so actually I
actually saw the report it was saying
things like I've had a lot of things
sorry they reported things like I've had
a lot of chances but because I didn't
feel like I was going to do it right and
they said the reason that they feel this
insecurity is because of social media
and you know in Social mediences really
because if I have a small Willy then I'm
not taking it out but I feel like if
yeah
Mr Esther I just want I was trying to
understand you so you're saying these
guys
have women that are down
okay okay wait so these 40 let me just
yeah I just want to make sure what they
say okay you're telling me these 40 of
men have guys or girls girls not guys
girls ready to sleep with them and
they're just saying you know what I
don't feel good about myself I'm not
going to no I'm not saying so many women
want to have sex with them I'm saying
these same men reported that they've
been in situations where they could have
had sex but they didn't feel confident
in themselves to say you know what I can
do this right but and you know where the
insecurity actually comes from other men
men go out talking about their game okay
oh I've got this you know I can pull any
girl it makes other men actually feel
insecure in themselves when actually in
reality women will have sex with any man
as long as you fulfill her needs it
doesn't have to be sexual it can be
emotional need it can speak for yourself
oh
sorry if this guy made you fall like a
queen email I'm sorry I'm a tall girl
I'm a tall girl I'm six foot right it
doesn't matter how good a 5'5 guy makes
me feel
special
I'm sorry look at it it's just if I was
shorter it'd be different but I'm tall
like but that's cute you could just like
okay you guys can do that that's fine
I'm not but the thing is aren't you
single are you single
yeah yeah then what what input do you
have on any of those what do you think
is it one of your big rows so like women
have standards that are too high and
they're not being realized blah blah
blah blah now you're looking for a guy
that's what six one at least
five five destiny five five five that's
what I said that's like 50 standard
deviations for the number hold on that's
what I'm saying
oh I'm sorry you can cut us off
I think you need to be careful okay I'm
fine
I said no God that is five five sorry
when people when people are talking
we're supposed to speak about for
everybody but then when every time you
give an example you go to like the
eighth standard deviation away from the
norm yeah how many guys are five five
it's like less than one percent okay
yeah look at five seven you know
okay so you think you think
you think it benefited man what do you
think Destiny I think there's pros and
cons to everybody that's going to be the
same for everything it's nice for women
because women can have more sex without
necessarily getting pregnant and having
kids women have a little bit more
Independence so they can explore
sexually without being tied down to one
man that they have to marry for men
there is more availability of sex I know
there was that 140 number but I think
that was uh quoted I want to say in 2021
it was like when the pandemic was crazy
and everything I think that fell I don't
know what it fell to
um but I mean like yeah like sex is more
available now than it was in the past
for most people which is but there's
pros and cons right there's going to be
more competition for sex there's going
to be more competition for relationships
back 30 40 50 years ago all a man had to
do was work a job and he was basically
like guaranteed a wife because women
couldn't work
um yeah I think it's important to
recognize our pros and cons to
everything can I point something out a
lot of the time you guys talk about this
80 20 ratio
um but like women are all gunning for
the same man and like
those studies that you
um reference they're all based on dating
apps like Okay Cupid and Tinder and I
just want to say like dating in the real
world is far different to our choices on
Tinder like uh there could be a perfect
man on a hinge and I will see lives in
dagenham
that is true that is true I'm crazy I'm
crazy on him as because we're looking
for everyone but if someone is in front
of me that that I get along with and I
can learn to love then all this nonsense
of marketization
right in yourself it's absolutely
the point is we swipe right on dating
apps what five percent of the time what
do you mean yeah but that's because wait
wait wait let me so so even if we we
triple it quadruple it that's still only
20 we could double it make it 40 it's
five to one men to women on these apps
of course women are going to be highly
highly and women are highly selective in
real life as well absolutely not not as
much as men as much as
do you think who's pick your men or
women when it comes to what when it
comes to four relationships for
relationships I think men tend to get
keep relationships more for sex women
you think men are equally picky when it
comes to relationships or sex let's say
relationships well it's important
because you guys mix them up a lot
I'm not mixing them sure okay for
relationships I think men can gatekeep
more than women do no I'm asking if you
think they're equally picky with the
women that they want to be in
relationships with as women are to men
um
are men as picky as women so so for you
if you were gonna if you were gonna I
mean you're already married right and
I'm I'm looking for a husband and you're
looking for a wife who's pickier
typically by and large I'm not not like
I'm just using it I think it's I think
it's roughly equal really that's so
interesting it's interesting but the
reason why is because you guys get all
your information from dating from dating
apps where the numbers are super skewed
but if you go into any school all the
boys are dating all the girls if you go
into any workplace
the girls when are environments where
men and women are together look at the
YouTube world and streamer every
YouTubers [__] every other YouTubers
that's how it works but the problem is
you guys are only looking at like well
look at Tinder where it's five men to
one woman I don't actually agree on
college campuses it's similar I would
say it's similar on college campuses
there's like a select group of men that
tend to do very well no hold on wait no
no wait you okay what you just said is a
highlight of why I think you're not
either engaging with no no wait because
you said men do very well
can I just I said a select group of men
you said it's like so for example like
athletes no one athlete is not dating
five women a select group of men they
might have sex but that's why I say it's
important to distinguish sex between
relationships an elite group of men can
[__] a lot of women sure only group of
women
yeah sure can I ask you a question okay
I'm not I'm not saying in terms of
relationships I'm saying in the initial
encounters where men come together with
women we're not even talking about
relationships now we're just that
initial moment when they meet who's
usually going to be more pickier who's
who's going to be more willing to like
settle with whatever comes their way
whatever you know they catch that night
or whenever they meet in in their real
life yeah when you've got to be more
who's going to be more picky picky
no I think no no no listen listen listen
before the sex or the relationship has
come yeah you first have to meet that
person and you subconsciously you know
in your mind not even subconsciously you
know in your mind if I would sleep with
that person or I would give them a
chance as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible